IT DOESN’T MAKE SENSE.
TUCKER, GOOD SHOW.
THANK YOU.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
ALL RIGHT, BUCKLE UP TONIGHT
BECAUSE WE HAVE A JAM-PACKED
SHOW.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR, ANDREW CUOMO
FACING ANOTHER MASSIVE SCANDAL.
WE WILL BRING YOU THE VERY
LATEST DETAILS STRAIGHT AHEAD AS
THE LEFT LIKES TO SAY.
THE WALLS ARE NOW CLOSING IN ON
ANDREW CUOMO.
THESE WALLS, WELL, PRETTY
INTERESTING.
THEY WERE ALL BUILT BY THE
DEMOCRATS, NOT REPUBLICANS.
ALSO TONIGHT, MITT ROMNEY
ADMITTING PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
BE THE 2024 NOMINEE IF HE
DECIDES TO RUN.
LAUREN TRUMP, SHE WILL REACT
TONIGHT WITH A FULL PREVIEW OF
THE PRESIDENT’S UPCOMING SPEECH
THIS WEEKEND AT CPAC.
BUT FIRST, BREAKING TONIGHT IN
WHAT MUST BE A TOTALLY
HUMILIATING TO JOE BIDEN, WE NOW
HAVE DOZENS OF HOUSE DEMOCRATS,
NOT REPUBLICANS, CALLING ON
JOE BIDEN TO RELINQUISH HIS SOLE
AUTHORITY TO THE NUCLEAR CODES.
YOU KNOW, THE NUCLEAR FOOTBALL?
IN A LETTER, THE DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER STATES ONE PERSON,
JOE BIDEN, WITH HIS AUTHORITY
ENTAILS REAL RISKS.
NOW, FIRST OF ALL, IT’S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THAT’S FIRST OF ALL.
THERE IS ONE COMMANDMENT IN
CHIEF.
IT IS NOT THE U.S. CONGRESS.
THERE IS ZERO CONSTITUTIONAL
AMBIGUITY HERE.
BUT SECOND OF ALL, WHAT DO THESE
DEMOCRATS KNOW ABOUT JOE BIDEN
THAT MAYBE THE REST OF US DON’T?
THEY DIDN’T PROPOSE THIS EVEN
WHEN DONALD TRUMP WAS
PRESIDENT AND THEY ALL HATED
DONALD TRUMP.
OBVIOUSLY, FROM OUR OWN
OBSERVATIONS COME AS WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING, AND IT’S INTERESTIN
EVEN OCCASIONALLY WHEN I SEE
PEOPLE IN THE MEDIA MOB, AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO ACT POLITE,
THEY WILL SAY, YEAH, WE ARE ALL
ON PINS AND NEEDLES EVERY TIME
JOE TALKS, BECAUSE WE CAN ALL
SEE WITH OUR OWN EYES.
YOU COMPARED TO
JOE BIDEN 4 YEARS AGO, 10 YEARS
AGO.
HE IS FRAIL.
HE IS WEAK.
AND HE IS STRUGGLING
COGNITIVELY.
IF HE EVER HAD A FASTBALL, I
WOULD ARGUE IT’S LONG GONE.
LET ME ALSO BE CLEAR, I’M NOT
MAKING ANY MEDICAL DIAGNOSIS
ABOUT JOE BIDEN AND THIS IS NOT
ABOUT HIS AGE.
FOR EXAMPLE, BERNIE SANDERS IS A
YEAR OLDER THAN JOE BIDEN HERE
AND HE HAS WAY MORE ENERGY, WAY
MORE STAMINA, WAY MORE MENTAL
ALERTNESS, FIGHTING EVERY DAY
FOR HIS INSANE SOCIALIST UTOPIA.
DONALD TRUMP, SIMILAR AGE,
BOUNDLESS ENERGY AND ALERTNESS.
JOE BIDEN ALWAYS SEEMS LIKE HE
NEEDS A NAP.
HE ALSO FREQUENTLY CONFUSES
NUMBERS, DATES, AND SOMETIMES
CAN BARELY GET THE WORDS OUT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA THAT OVER 500, I
THINK IT’S, I HAVE A CARD.
I CARRY A CARD ON ME EVERY DAY.
A NUMBER OF FOLKS WHO HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED.
FULLY VACCINATE 300 AMERICANS.
BY
THE END OF THE SUMMER, THE
BEGINNING OF THE FALL.
BUT WE WANT TO MAKE --
I WANT TO REPEAT, THERE WILL BE
ENOUGH TO FULLY VACCINATE 300
AMERICANS TO BEAT THIS PANDEMIC.
300 MILLION AMERICANS.
GOING THIS WAY.
THANK YOU ALL.
>> THE SENATOR WHO IS A MORMON.
OR GOVERNOR.
OKAY?
WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
EVIDENT.
YOU KNOW THE THING.
>> Sean: THIS ISN’T ABOUT A
FEW GAPS.
LOOK, HE REPORTEDLY GOES TO BED
VERY, VERY EARLY.
HE HAS FEW PUBLIC EVENTS.
VICE PRESIDENT, HARRIS IS TAKING
A WHOLE LOT OF SOLO CALLS WITH
FOREIGN LEADERS ON BEHALF OF
JOE.
A LITTLE ODD IN THE END OF
ITSELF.
AND HE NEVER MISSES ANY
OPPORTUNITY WHATSOEVER TO CALL
AN EARLY LID ON THE DAY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE WON’T BE
SEEING OR HEARING FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
RECENTLY HE TOOK A SNOW DAY
AFTER THE WHITE HOUSE GOT A
WHOPPING 2 INCHES OF SNOW.
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL, HE BARELY
HAD ANY PUBLIC EVENTS AT ALL.
HE COWERED IN HIS BASEMENT
BUNKER.
THE MEDIA MOB, THEY SHIELDED HIM
FROM ANY AND ALL NEGATIVE
STORIES AND PRETTY MUCH
CAMPAIGNED ON HIS BEHALF AND
WENT OUT TRASHING HIS OPPONENT
EVERY SECOND OF EVERY DAY.
WE CALLED IT ON THIS PROGRAM
"THE CANDIDATE PROTECTION
PROGRAM."
AND IT WAS, TO BE HONEST, PRETTY
EFFECTIVE.
ONE POLL CONDUCTED AFTER THE
ELECTION SHOWED
THAT 1 AND 6 BIDEN VOTERS WOULD
HAVE CHANGED THEIR MINDS HAD
THEY KNOWN THE FULL DETAILS
ABOUT BIDEN’S VARIOUS SCANDALS,
INCLUDING THE, YES, VERY TRUE
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP STORY FROM
"THE NEW YORK POST."
BUT NOW JOE BIDEN IS PRESIDENT
AND DEMOCRATS ARE APPARENTLY SO
WORRIED ABOUT HIS ABILITY TO
FULFILL HIS DUTIES AS COMMANDER
IN CHIEF, THEY WANT HIM TO HAND
OVER THE NUCLEAR CODES?
REMEMBER, THIS IS NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO, AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP’S TOUR WAS
COMING TO AN END, NANCY PELOSI,
REMEMBER SHE BACKED UP THE BILL
THAT WOULD DETERMINE A PRESIDENT
’ASKED FITNESS FOR OFFICE
CUSTOMER SHE SAID THE BILL
WASN’T ABOUT DONALD TRUMP.